alors alain bashung bonsoir bonsoir
bon
or tous ces indices qu'ils appellent
novices ouais les exégètes se sont mis
au travail à laurianne novice n
obéissent et eux comme c'est écrit sur
la pochette
il ya aussi novice n os bsnes uno vice
en anglais tu penses quoi de ce genre de
tu comprends tout ce que tout ce que buy
ont été sur toi dans dans libération
c'est une bonne question est est-ce que
tu comprends moi je ne cherche pas et
moi je serai pas à comprendre les
finitions des pleines pages sur toi mais
c'est toujours un peu compliqué il
raconte une aventure et il délire et
c'est une façon de parler de quelque
chose tu peux en parler avec le médecin
en décortiquant musicalement dit dans
quel musicien c'est pas mal ou luke
c'est super ça c'est un aspect mais leur
angle légendaire je trouve ça rend sa
légendaire les personnes ya toi yam ans
et gagnera des gainsbourg et du tronc
vous êtes ses légendes ses biens bah oui
je suis surtout content que
avec et des personnes qui comprennent à
la limite tout ce que je dis portes il
ya quand même deux tendances dans ce que
tu fais yalla yalla ligne dure
ces play blessures setek nos colonnes un
peu comme ça c'est ce que tu as appelé
la cacophonie rigoureuse où les erreurs
délibéré un sas et le balch ou un peu
artiste me dit un peu un peu hard et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui quand on
écoute play blessures
c'est beaucoup plus classique ou plus
facile que quand on écoute et la
première fois les pieds un peu le côté
top 50 ouailles à pizza et a passé le
rio grande et c'était comme ça à bourg
et de calembours 1 et qui a été meilleur
disque de rock de l'année une autre
c'est entre ces deux lignes comme ça
entre la la ligne dure et la ligne pizza
disons tout sens où là bas depuis depuis
ben tu connaissais le disque avant itza
il y avait roulette russe et c'était
s'était pas vraiment
une forme de tore boyau à part quand
même c'est un peu ténébreux mais je
crois que ça m'a aidé à prendre du recul
sur moi enfin tu vois je tous ces mecs
qui gamberge trou comme ça que j'en fais
partie je me pose trop de questions et
puis finalement on sait bien aussi tu
vas mais ça me permet de s'ouvrir temps
en temps c'est cher indices comme ça à
produire normalement ça doit pas être
cher je trouve que le dernier a coûté
trop cher les navires et combien lannoy
lys
je sais pas peut-être 80 75 bruxelles
huawei un truc comme ça
mais si je trouve je trouve ça
scandaleux enfant il faut rendre combien
pour rembourser mais je sais pas
peut-être 80 mille cent mille arrive
comme ça oui c'est envisageable
ah oui bah je le vends correctement des
albums donc se rendre
il scelle fais pas chier de compte et
était comptable côté des petits noirs
j'ai failli être considérés comment
alors bastion cantal
c'était un mec qui était sur des rails
parfait pour lui tu vas g
j'ai fait un stage chez péchiney il faut
encore
il fallait faire il fallait faire un
dossier non pour passer l'examen
ce rendu compte à quel point c'était pas
fait pour moi et j'ai eu un refus du
chiffre total est et je n'aurais
peut-être pas dû avoir un refus
systématique du système de furie celui
ci voulait pas voir le métier de ton
père boulanger
non j'ai taquiner un peu quand j'étais
petit parce que j'étais un peu je
viserai d
des gâteaux pour les mariages d immense
gâteau guide est trois fois plus grand
que moi j'avais des pourboires et puis
parce qu il restait dans la farine
non le pétrin du cub3 dans les sorties
way est prêté en alsace mes parents j'ai
pas mal de difficultés à un d'hydra
parise avait une petite pièce suivante
j'ai parti chez la grand-mère de
services quoi c'est que sympa
un petit village bon c'est pas facile
d'être de nulle part de bbc sacré
détruit familiaux un peu de vent mais
elle est blues je te piquer je t'en prie
merci de prêter a fait pas mal de
galères quand même c'est vrai que tu as
été producteur de dick rivers oui j'ai
fait ça pendant trois ans ce qui allait
abandonner toutes les leçons devant de
la scène
le climat s'y prêtait pas seul le seul
darche qui fait des trucs sauf à y en
avait quelques-uns y avait du tronc non
c'est bon
c'était une période
très variés têtu
pas forcément c'est le moment le plus
dur à cette époque le truc que tu
voudrais plus jamais revivre
je vivais avec une femme c'était le bac
aussi
non je crois que c'est qu'est ce qu'elle
pensait qu'au fric et moi je moi je
pouvais gagner de l'argent à travers une
passion et je pouvais pas me dire
maintenant il faut que je gagne de
l'argent et la passion des rapts et
j'avais ça en tête je pouvais pas
exister autrement alors si je sais pas
si c'est très égoïste quoi servent les
artistes parce que moi et j'étais comme
ça tu vois je j'essaie de faire plein de
jeux de jobs et rien ne va rien de
décoller au moyen de réussite sûrs alors
je trafique et un peu à gauche à droite
tu fais une commune et musicale
je faisais en faisait des cover l'époque
de
d'autres artistes ont récompensé les
plus grands succès de géniale idée par
exemple jouer avec sa photo avait chanté
par le bi li chn tu vas et c'était toi
qui existent mais moi je faisais les
voir au que wayne lord charles xavier de
le rue church omid en soit cet ennui
quand on dit qu'elle est géniale idée de
la new wave c'est un peu ce un peu
théorique voix pour moi mais ça c'est
peut-être pas complètement non
c'est pas totalement faux certainement
parce que mon grade il était
à commencer par du rock quand même il
n'a pas baigné forcément dans la musique
classique
à ce moment là il ya des moments te dis
j'y arriverai jamais je vais je n'avais
rien à [ __ ] de me réveiller le matin
je souhaitais stade là puis un jour ça
allait tellement mal que je me suis dit
c'est là que tu découvres que finalement
tu peux pas descendre plus bas et tu
veux remonter quoi tu as vu que je suis
ici voilà quand même c'est le classique
mais c'est vrai c'est pas des conneries
maintenant tu tape un peu le look
famille bien le dire
le steeple tu viens atterrés nous parler
de ton petit arthur qui vais bientôt
aussi célèbre que le petit lu web et je
peux pas faire oublier là dessus dit
comme ça c'est pas gênant pour les fans
9 -10 troy
je crois pas parce que je j'ai des cuves
vraiment cette période là c'est pas
comme si je racontais des histoires de
science fiction tu vas et je souhaite à
personne d'être de plus de vivre ça dans
cet état
je crois qu'il faut y arriver une autre
manière on peut y arriver d'autres
manières si elle est n'est pas forcément
facile
il ya un moment 82 tu disais
fa c'est je crois le moment tu tu es
séparer de bergman pendant un moment et
u10 et j'étais à deux doigts de la mort
se dire quoi ce nom il fallait que
gérard dufour fallait que j'arrête un
peu surpris mais en suisse
comme une star comme ça vous a fait la
clinique ensuite la clinique en suisse
tout parfaitement règlements clairs et
maintenant tu vois plus que du café
kwaito huawei là c'est pareil j'étais un
prix à un moment où tu sais que tu as
fait ton des problèmes
j'ai goûté à boeufs pas mal de trucs et
c'était bien
alors bon le médecin il te dit un jour
écoute tu t'arrêtes de l'ukraine
et puis voilà tu vas pas bien ce bourg
il gère beaucoup moi j'avais beaucoup
donc
imagine qu'ils marchent pas le disque la
novice tu te diras quoiqu'il ait pas bon
c'est les gens qui sont pas bons ce qui
est important c'est que je vois d'accord
avec cet album j'ai lâché d'accord non
je suis pas totalement blindés mais ce
qui me paraît le plus important c'est
d'être d'abord d'accord avec cet album
et ensuite on verra